hello everyone welcome to a another
edition of uh humor talks uh where I'm
talking with different people promoting
humor in the workplace today we've got
two uh great guys from peppercomm
they'll be talking a a little bit about
uh standup comedy because they've done a
unique thing with their organization uh
in the workplace so uh with me today are
Clayton and Steve how are you guys doing
today excellent Andrew how are you I'm
doing well doing well so um before we
jump into the standup comedy stuff just
give me a little bit of background what
is exactly does H peppercomm do we uh we
do everything but windows so um by that
I mean we are um we are a fully
integrated strategic and marketing
Communications firm heavily into public
relations but we also do web design
events crisis work um for a lot of
Fortune 500 companies that you'd
recognize okay great yeah so like you
said everything but uh but Windows one
of the yeah one of the services that you
offer is something called The Comedy
experience and it's actually related to
stand of Comedy so how exactly does
peppercomm the marketing stuff that
they're doing and relate to the standup
comedy world so my name is Clayton
Fletcher and I'm the chief comedy
officer at peppercomm and I'm in charge
of something called pepperon comedy
experience featuring Clayton Fletcher or
as we like to call it PC FCF uh what it
is is uh an opportunity for companies to
learn things that standup comedians know
with the goal of applying those uh those
bits of information to their uh to their
day-to-day work so whether it's using
standup comedy skills in your business
presentations or as a culture shift
agent or uh as internal Communications
we found that a lot of things that you
learn from doing standup comedy would
help you in the workplace so as part of
our culture here at peppercomm I train
uh along with Steve Cody here uh we
train the employes uh at
peppercomm comedy improv comedy sketch
comedy and script
writing with the uh intention of
informing our culture with standup
comedy and with uh the joy of laughter
and it's actually gotten us some recent
accolades uh cranes New York Nam Us best
place to work in New York City oh wow
wow yeah I can see if people are
enjoying their work and actually going
into the workplace and laughting some
there's gonna they're probably going to
enjoy that work a little bit more and of
course it's going to be a good work
environment as well um so how did how
did does an idea like training uh
employees on standup comedy actually
start in the workplace how does that
come about well I I um I decided about
seven or eight years ago to do it as a
one-off bucket list type of of of
experience and I just happened to go
through a program that Clayton was
running uh as a professional comedian
his his night job as professional
comedian his day job as Chief comedy
officer
at pepper comp Clayton made great titles
to have yeah exactly Clayton made the
mistake of of telling me after my debut
that I wasn't bad and I should try it
again so so I got hooked and after a
couple of years of doing it on a regular
basis I started noticing I became uh a
little bit more Adept uh in the business
World in terms of both uh verbal and and
non-verbal skills um decided that my
management committee could benefit from
this so I had Clayton train them during
an offsite once they experienced that
they said we have to do this as part of
our regular Management training program
that in turn generated buzz in the pr
and advertising trades and companies
started calling us asking if we could
help them break down silos get people to
work better together and also help um
bring some authenticity and Truth to
their corporate storytelling because
what Clayton will tell you is that
stand-up comedy is based upon telling
the
truth yeah that that idea of Truth and
comedy um a book that Chara H WR
specifically kind of on the world of
improv but certainly kind of applies
here in terms of those those factual
things how was the response initially
when you started to when you let your
kind of employees know like hey you're
going to do some standup comedy was it
and R right away were people a little
bit apprehensive what was that kind of
like it's uh you know you know what it
didn't doesn't matter whether it's
peppercomm or a Fortune 500 company or a
group of doctors and nurses the initial
reaction is somewhere between skepticism
and outright
hostility and by the time they go
through the experience there is so much
love and warmth and boy you've got to
come back and do this again that it's um
it's the single best transformational
experience and team building experience
I've I've ever um seen or participated
in so to answer your question it goes
from negativity to um empathy sympathy
support wanting
more absolutely that's an incredible
transformation for any type of of
training to be able to to go through for
those to be the end results are
incredibly kind of powerful in today's
you know work environment so what so you
kind of mentioned some of them as well
what are some of the benefits of a group
going through a program like this well
it's it's um it's akin to um a platoon
fighting in
Vietnam it's uh it is uh it is a uh an
intense raw
experience in which each one of the
group members knows that he or she will
be trained but will be going in front of
his or her peers to tell three or four
minutes of real things that bug them um
um offend them upset them anything from
you know a spouse who snores to a train
a a commute That Never Ends uh to a
sports team that never wins so um it's
really fascinating to to see the the
when Clayton says Okay who wants to go
first there are no hands and then
finally someone says okay I'll do it um
tremendous warmth surrounding that
individual then after she is done you'll
see two hands pop up and about halfway
through you'll see 8 10 12 I want to go
next I want to go next kind of thing so
the bonding is absolutely amazing yeah
well as you know uh Andrew you've done
St of Comedy yourself and and you know
that it's a scary thing to try but uh
and most people they say their biggest
fear in life is public speaking so s
comedy like public speaking where you're
actually expected to get a laugh every 5
Seconds
so it puts a little extra pressure on it
but you know a lot of companies uh they
they want to build their teams and team
building is a big buzz work um you know
HR companies they they want to they want
to have team building and so they try
different exercises and not putting
those exercises down but you know how
about I'm going to fall backwards and
see if Brad's going to catch me or not
or right the thing was I play the
telephone game I'll whisper in your ear
you whisper in Sean's ear and we'll see
what what kind of story We Tell at the
end and all those things are fun and
they they can be just a nice little uh
break from the day to day but the
difference that we found is when you
teach people the art of standup comedy
and basing it on the truth and you
referenced you know shaa halper's book
with d close um which is a book that I'm
a huge fan of by the way uh you you need
the truth the truth must be present or
else it's just not as funny often it's
not funny at all whenever I'm in a
comedy club and I see a comedian
Desperately Seeking those laps but he's
doing it in every way other than
authenticity and they tend to fail
because the culture nowadays is about
truth reality television authenticity
you know American Idol does a lot better
than than any uh you know U you know
sitcom or any non you any fictional
account so that's what it's all about
and and you know comedy is just one way
to improve your communication skills and
we found it's also a lot of fun
absolutely yeah I think it's it's really
powerful the work that you're doing
because psychologists have shown that
when people have shared experiences
whether they're positive or negative
that group of people becomes closer
together and kind of you guys are
hitting it from both angles that initial
fear feeling of like you mentioned with
the platoon that feeling of like oh man
we have to go through this whole stand
up thing together that brings them
closer together but then by the end of
it they've learned a ton about each
other as you're talking about like with
the them kind of sharing true stories
and they last together which is
tremendously powerful for bringing
people closer together as well yeah and
and the other interesting thing um um
side effect or phenomenon is after
someone has has undergone the training
making a business presentation seems
like a walk in the park oh yeah
absolutely so so it also gives them a
quiet confidence uh and also a little
bit of bragging rights that you know hey
I just and and by the way many of the of
our people and we've also done this with
clients have gone on to perform in clubs
in Manhattan at at real shows so quite a
few people don't just do it in the
workplace they'll go on to the Broadway
Comedy Club the New York comedy club and
other venues where Clayton will put them
on the bill oh that's great yeah that
didn't make stranger laugh is incredibly
like it it's me having done it um and
still doing it it is a little bit
addicting where it's like wow this
feeling of making strangers or other
people in a room laugh at these kind of
ideas and thoughts that you have is uh
is pretty powerful definitely Andrew and
you you alluded a moment ago to uh the
bonding that comes from a shared
experience and the bonding properties of
of Comedy um and I always make a
differentiation between comedy and humor
like in my view humor is anything that
makes you smile and comedy is anything
that makes you laugh and as as you
probably know from your study in this
field the uh the
physiological effects of laughter are
very real um you know endorphins are
released in the brain convincing the
person who's laughing that that he or
she is falling in love uh it's the exact
same chemical reaction from laughter as
it is from falling in love or exercising
or eating chocolate so we always joke
that if you really want someone to fall
in love with you feed them chocolate
while they're on a treadmill and tell
them a joke at the same time that all
your basis covered but but what we found
is that the bonding that that takes
place through that laughter is extremely
powerful and it's just a much more
effective team building exercise than
anything else that we've seen on the in
the
market absolutely and so in addition to
some of the things that I kind of
explore and I'm wondering if you guys
kind of feel the the same way is that
obviously it's a great uh kind of
program for helping to improve kind of
relationship within the uh work
organization through team building you
also kind of mentioned on communication
skills being able to clearly kind of
communicate ideas and also people are
more likely to remember things if they
kind of laughed or they received them in
a humorous way I've also seen humor be
you know incredibly helpful with
improving kind of problem solving skills
you know increasing creativity and kind
of that thought process as well as um
helping to increase productivity having
a little bit more fun and that kind of
thing what are the types of different
transferable skills that you see from
people doing the standup comedy stuff
that then relate into actual workplace
kind of gain you know so it's not just
say just for fun thing which I think is
a huge component of it but do you see
other benefits to it as well yeah I I
think one of the fundamental challenges
the average business executive fais is
when he or she is either you know
talking oneto one or making some sort of
presentation and dealing with either a
distracted or neutral audience so in
other words filling the silence filling
those awkward gaps um the people who go
through and our employees and our
clients who go through the training are
given a whole new set of skills to turn
that either passive or you know God
forbidden negative reaction into a more
positive one that actually can turn
around a meeting on a dime and that is
absolutely invaluable whether you're
trying to um um sell a program within
the organization a to someone who
controls the budget or differentiate
yourself um and get on the fast track
within the organization or in a sales
situation where everything else is equal
connect and build better rapport with
the prospect so there is some very real
business skills that are transferable
above and beyond team building
absolutely and so um as people are kind
of thinking about this what does the
kind of the program experience kind of
look like is it a one day kind of half
day or full day is it a you meet a
couple of different times what's the
process like going from transferring uh
transforming someone that's never done
standup comedy before and that is that
has that negative reaction to by the end
of the day they're you know standing up
there and telling uh a story in front of
people and getting laughs or maybe even
going on to a comedy club what does the
program look like yeah um what the way
we do it Andrew we tailor the uh PC FCF
to a company needs so if a company is
looking for a one- day team building
exercise we can use it for that purpose
but where we really think it's true
Powers Unleashed is when it's used as an
ongoing culture agent so you know it's
similar to what I've done actually here
at
peppercomm management team then it's
well why don't we do comedy with the
whole company and then it becomes you
know everything from you know the way
that we email each other to the way we
communicate with our business partners
and our clients and our potential
clients to even the way we do charity
you know peppercomm is very active in
the philanthropic side and what we do is
typically when a company such as a
Leukemia Lymphoma Society or Autism
Speaks or any number of young survival
Coalition any number of breast cancer um
different types of Charities that come
to us they say can you help us plan an
event because again pepper com is also
in the business of event planning well
say well we have a great idea that might
be a little different for you how about
if we do a night of standup comedy and
we'll actually teach some of your
employees to do comedy and so then that
becomes a win-win because then the
charity is actively involved in the in
the actual event so they've learned to
do comedy and of course everyone's
curious to see that person you know who
heads up the uh you know whatever the
New York division of of this autism
charity or whatever the case may be
actually planning to go up on stage for
5 minutes and try to be funny you know
and Steve and I work with that person
make sure that he or she is ready to to
go up there and really kill it at the
comedy club and then we surround them
with uh with love and professional
Comedians and and and we sometimes do
like a charity auction in addition to
all that so what we've learned is that
usually whatever the question is we try
to see if the answer might be comedy and
I out 10 it is yeah and Andrew just to
elaborate on that um most of the clients
not all but most most of the clients for
whom we've done work are in some sort of
transition they've either merged they've
downsized um they've gone through some
sort of seismic event in which there are
any number of silos or distinct groups
that for a variety of reasons need to
come together work together better be
more productive and all of that
obviously will impact morale but
typically that's the problem but we've
done a lot of work in very serious
medical and pharmaceutical areas where
empathy and listening skills are
absolutely critical so we trained
several hundred doctors and nurses who
deal with stage four level cancer
patients and they told us look when we
went through John's Hopkins nobody
taught us how to break the news and how
to react so how do we use how do we use
standup comedy to become more empathetic
and and perhaps ease the pain of
breaking that news which is not to imply
that you would actually make a joke at
that moment as you're telling someone he
has stage four cancer but of course
right you learn skills in comedy as far
as being authentic and and sharing and
just being vulnerable and and being
sympathetic to someone else and reading
your audience and all those different
skills that comedians know are actually
quite transferable to that space as well
and U but I'm still here with you okay
uh great thank you Steve for for
dropping in maybe Clayton if you can can
uh stay on for a few more minutes would
love to ask a couple of questions um
yeah one of I think the points kind of
just to build off of what you guys are
talking about is that Studies have shown
that people with the high kind of rating
and sense of humor are also highly
related in emotional intelligence uh so
having that ability to be more uh
empathetic kind of with people and have
that understanding and really understand
kind of human behavior and human Dynamic
I think is an important skill to teach
and standup comedy can be great and fun
way to to actually teach it which uh
sounds you know sounds really cool in
terms of the work that you guys are
doing yeah we never we never say that
we're trying to find uh America's Next
Top standup comedian or you know it's
not like there's going to be a casting
director from HBO in the audience that
night or something you know these events
that we plan are very controlled and you
know if someone's doing comedy for the
first time just getting up on stage as
you know Andrew since you've done it
just getting up on stages of victory in
itself because know it's it's something
that most people say oh I could never do
what you do and and now here they are
actually doing it so you know that in
itself is is powerful but what you learn
once you're up there another thing we'll
do is we'll go back later with the
company we'll sit down with each
employee individually and watch videos
of those firsttime standup comedy
performances and then we usually
blackmail them and threaten to post the
videos on
YouTube of course we don't do that but
yeah we we'll sit down with them and go
go over almost like a football coach
would with his team after the game and
say here here's a here's the time where
you could have done this or or when you
said that you see how that really landed
and here's why look at your body
language listen to your your tonality
and your voice and just you know look at
the fun that you were having while you
were saying that to the audience and
then there's so many lessons to be
learned just from watching yourself and
the way you present yourself and even if
you're not training to be a presenter uh
we all have to present ourselves you
know in some way on a day-to-day basis
and you know everyone can benefit from
these
skills yeah absolutely so uh talking
again a little bit about the experience
um and you kind of alluded to it here in
terms of getting feedback and stuff like
that but what does the uh what does the
person that's going through this kind of
go through I know it changes based on
the program but is it something where
they just kind of get up and try stuff
do you give them tips on like here's the
rule of three in comedy or here's how to
do like kind of set up in punch and then
do they perform for kind of each other
in the group or is there a larger
audience kind of what what does that
process look like a little bit sure yeah
let me walk you through a typical PC FCF
uh say we have a company and they have a
division that's uh now been married uh
so they had a restructuring and all of a
sudden John who doesn't even know Bob
has to share a cubicle with him and all
of a sudden you know uh Mary and Barbara
never worked together before so the
company brings us into help help break
down some of those silos and and break
the walls down so the first thing we'll
do is we'll introduce ourselves and
explain what peppercomm is and how I'm
the chief comedy officer and what that
involves and then we'll talk a little
bit about uh why we should use comedy in
the workplace so that's the first
question we ask is why and and I don't
do this part as the lecture we talk to
their employees and very often we get
surprising answers from the company um
you know things that are going on behind
the scenes start to come out right away
which is great for us because the more
information we have the better we can
tailor the event to you know to the yeah
so then once we get a feel for why we're
doing this in the first place then we
start to talk about the ways we use
comedy to solve whatever particular
problems have come up in the initial
discussion and then I start giving them
some nuts and bolts you know I talk
about different styles of standup comedy
whether it be observational or anecdotal
or you know what have you put down humor
all the different types of Comedy that
are out there and which ones are are
appropriate or inappropriate for the
workplace then we'll talk about some
more nuts and bolts terms like you
already use such as setups and
punchlines the differences and
characteristics of a good punchline
characteristics of a
setup and we'll use examples uh from my
own uh standup comedy routine or that of
Steve Cody or you know maybe even citing
you know famous people such as Chris
rocker Jerry Seinfeld or Bill Cosby my
personal favorite um great yeah we'll
talk about that and then and then I'll
give them some specific techniques that
comedians use now here I'm talking about
things like exaggeration or act outs or
call backs and you know all these words
that comedians know what these things
are and we use them every single night
but the average workplace you know the
average businessman he doesn't know what
that is and how it's used and why it's
powerful and so we'll talk about it and
then I assist them with a
brainstorm so we don't just say all
right now every every body give it up
and try it no we we'll take the next 10
or 15 minutes try to come up with a
couple ideas what you would talk about
if you ever got up on stage we make a
point of letting everyone know that no
one's going to be forced to do it but
that we're going to strongly encourage
everyone to at least give it a try at
least the writing part so that you would
try to come up with an exercise and then
in the brainstorm I try to get them to
share the truth you know you want to use
the truth you want to talk about
something that happened in your life or
something that you saw on Tel ision that
you had a strong reaction to and the key
there with observational in particular
is that I feel the comedian has to have
an emotional response to it you know
absolutely you have to say I can't
believe this happened or I really hate
that commercial or I really love what
Obama said at the you know State of the
Union Address whatever your opinion is
there has to be a strong emotional
connection to it and then that point of
view is so so important in terms of
creating a a brand economy that's
specific to you like what is your
perspective on that situation how does
it make you feel and what's your
reaction to it I think that's great
exactly because you don't want to have a
standup comedy act that any other
comedian could ever do so it has to be
Uniquely Yours and I think the key to
finding that stuff that no one can even
steal if they try is it has to be coming
from your heart from your true feelings
and so we work with them on that and
then you know to be honest a lot of
times what we end up getting once the
employees actually do get up is tell
stories very often stories from the
workplace that often lead us back to the
initial issues that were uh addressed in
the beginning of the session so um that
that can be fun because now we're
learning how to laugh at the fact that
life is imperfect and that work is
imperfect and that literally nothing's
perfect and so if we can laugh at it
maybe we can look at it a little bit
more objectively and actually solve the
problems and so then afterwards uh you
know we'll get up as many employees as
we can whatever time allows and then you
know there's usually lunch break and
then after lunch we'll do some more
exercises which could involve anything
from um you know improv training such as
uh some of the things that are found in
the in the book that we were talking
about earlier truth and comedy or just
different exercises that I've done in my
improv career uh we might work on some
writing some sketch writing uh we might
try to make some funny videos like one
to two minute uh comedy videos that then
become viral viral back at that
workplace um you know the way we spend
the rest of that day could be you know
almost anything and then we'd like to if
if there's time we like to review those
videos although very often we have to
come back on another day to do that
right and then what we do is we go back
to senior leadership at that company and
we'll say what did we learn today and
what would you like to do going forward
and then we help develop a program for
them like if their problem happens to be
internal communication then we'll work
with them on ways to use comedy
techniques and they bring us back back
you know either every other week or once
a month or whatever the case may be
where we can work with them on using
these comedy techniques and these skills
that comedians have trying to develop
those skills in the workplace with the
specific goal of solving whatever
individual problems have been pointed
out to us by the company itself as being
a particular need so it's not just a fun
day of doing comedy but It ultimately
becomes a solution to a real problem
within the culture absolutely yeah it's
it's definitely more than just even that
team building element is a great way to
kind of get
into um some of the other issues that
might be uh that comedy might be the
kind of right solution to help solve so
open that box for you absolutely uh so
kind of as we wrap up how do you think
how do we get this into more companies
it seems like it's tremendously valuable
so what are your thoughts in terms of is
this something that other organizations
need if so how did they go about
starting to do something like this well
uh the best way to do it in my opinion
we've spent seven years working on this
and and finding out what works and what
doesn't work um so we encourage
companies to get in touch with
peppercomm you can visit our website
peppercomm sure you'll put the link up
on your site as well absolutely and get
in touch with us and we can tailor uh we
can tailor this service offering to each
individual company based on what their
needs are for some companies it might
just be a half day for other companies
might more of an ongoing program and we
willing to to talk with with the
companies and try to develop a a tailor
made solution for them that involves uh
as I like to put it why we should mix
business and comedy as I've actually
done in my own career you know after I
get off the phone with you I'm going to
an audition and then tonight I'm going
to be doing uh two performances in
comedy clubs around Manhattan so I
certainly mix business and comedy in my
life and I think that everyone should
and we're ready to prove it awesome
excellent well yeah like you mentioned
I'll certainly include a link to that I
think that's a great next step for
people to go and and check it out and I
do think that it is something that's
tremendously valuable um in a number of
different types of organization so
Clayton thanks so much for uh talking
with us today and thanks give our thanks
to uh Steve as well uh for great Insight
yeah absolutely really enjoyed talking
with you today Andrew thank you very
much alrighty thank you
he